if it were not for acting but if we were
given the award for eyebrows who would
if it was a battle of the eyebrows I'm
gonna have to say Dan really new school
I'm just I'm going with something that's
a little Wilder for Eugene's eyebrows I
want that when I want to be taken
seriously Dan takes care of and then Dan
just like like got a little more trend
going on a little more angular at a
party a bit of a party I want to wear
him when I'm going out and I'm
pretending I'm not a 36 year old woman
dad because they're they literally come
out he turns inside and they literally
come out to here it's funny you should
ask me because when I'm not working
my hobby is threading are they related
for 30 years I've been looking at his
eyebrows dan's are kind of new to me you
have to always honor legacy all the time
they're Hall of Fame the fact that he
might have a connected eyebrow excites
me a little bit of tinsel goes a long
way there's only two eyebrows in that
photo so I suppose pick left or right I
don't know I have to say Dan or he will
murder me in my sleep
I grew mine a little bit Jessie told me
jessie was here and she said that you
did I think there's a little bit of a
unibrow maintenance my dad lets us go
which i think is a very admirable thing
right yeah so he probably has the better
eyebrows just because they're more
voluminous I will say that in this room
your brows are overwhelmingly the
favorite
well I think that's that deserves some
cash